did you know we've left 96 bags of poo
and pee up on the moon they're from the
Apollo Moon missions back in the 60s
after collecting lunar rocks to bring
back to Earth the astronauts left the
bags on the moon to lighten their cargo
load they've been sitting there in the
lunar dust for over six decades
astrobiologists have considered bringing
the poop back to Earth and studying the
bacteria they want to see if it's
evolved in any strange ways due to the
higher levels of radiation the moon
receives now if you think that's weird
it's only gonna get crazier we've left
some pretty wild things in space from
kitchen appliances to Art made for
aliens
some of the weirdest things are golf
balls in a 1971 Mission To The Moon
astronaut Alan Shepard snuck the head of
a six iron and a few golf balls on board
he created a makeshift golf club by
attaching the head to the shaft of a
piece of rock collecting equipment
Shepard didn't stop there he went ahead
and hit a couple of balls he said they
went a couple hundred meters so he
didn't bother collecting them leaving
them on the moon
in 1977 when Voyager 1 and 2 were
launched a special item was put on board
Carl Sagan and his team created a 30
centimeter golden LP record for each
ship the record came with instructions
on how to play it and was intended to be
a Showcase of Earth and Humanity in the
event it was stumbled upon by an alien
species the record included 115 images
greetings in 55 languages and what
amounts to a 90-minute mixtape of Music
throughout cultures and history now the
voyagers are still out there and it's
unclear if anyone or anything has found
them
well if aliens ever found Voyager and
decided to visit us well we better make
sure the Earth is still safe and
thriving I don't know if aliens drink
water but you sure do and you need to
know that your TAP water's safe
unfortunately this is where the bad news
comes in a recent studies revealed that
nearly half of U.S tap water could be
contaminated with harmful chemicals
those are the kind of chemicals that
don't break down in your body yeah
that's concerning and marginalized
communities are affected the most did
you know that 75 percent of black
Americans are likely to live near
facilities that pollute and Hispanic
Americans are twice as likely to live
where drinking water isn't even up to
Legal standards what's worse Congress
has redirected 2.3 billion dollars away
from fixing our water system but here's
where you come in together we can make
some noise and get our leaders to take
some action let's push for replacing
lead pipes and repairing old
infrastructure join together weather for
cleaner water we've got to keep the
planet safe right
during a 2006 flight to the ISS
astronaut Pierce sellers was out
spacewalking to make some repairs to the
ship he had to spread a special goo and
to do so he decided to use his favorite
spatula before he knew it sellers lost
grip of the spatula causing it to drift
out into space well if aliens find it
they'll be able to make some eggs or
flip some burgers
now not only is there pee on the moon
but did you know there's P floating
around in space yeah when astronauts
would pee on a spaceship they'd dump the
urine overboard causing it to
crystallize in space and Float around
like tiny debris according to astronauts
this is one of the most beautiful sights
you can find in the vastness of space
Unfortunately they don't get to see it
anymore P recycling systems have been
implemented they turn astronauts pee
into drinkable water resulting in less
pee debris
one of the very first items left in
space was an astronaut's glove Ed White
an American spacewalker lost his glove
on the 1965 Gemini 4 flight
unfortunately the glove is long gone it
was in space for about a month and then
it burned up re-entering the Earth's
atmosphere
not all items on our list were lost some
were purposely thrown out sometimes NASA
deems cargo too heavy to take back to
Earth so things get thrown out into
space that's what happened in 2007 a 635
kilogram tank of ammonia was thrown
overboard at a space station the ammonia
was part of the cooling system but when
the AC was upgraded the ammonia became
unnecessary a year after it was thrown
out it burned up while falling toward
the South Pacific Ocean
in 1992 ashes from the legendary Star
Trek Creator Gene Roddenberry ended up
in space it was one of his last requests
before he died a small capsule of his
ashes flew up in a spaceship and was
then thrown overboard it most likely
burned up in the atmosphere shortly
after
before the Apollo 12 mission sculptor
Forrest Myers had an idea to bring a
piece of art to the Moon he decided to
take this small ceramic wafer and get
six artists to sketch on it one of them
being Andy Warhol Myers could never
convince an astronaut to bring the art
on board so instead he convinced an
engineer working on Apollo 12. the
engineer hid the ceramic wafer
underneath the gold blanket that was on
the bottom half which ended up crashing
on the moon now we should mention that
NASA has never officially confirmed this
but Myers claims it's true
while using a lunar rover to explore the
moon Charles Duke left a family photo of
himself his wife and his kids on the
back Duke wrote a message in case anyone
found it this is the family of astronaut
Duke from planet Earth landed on the
moon April 1972.
one piece of art that is confirmed to be
on the moon is this aluminum statuette
it's known as the Fallen astronaut and
it's next to a plaque with the names of
14 astronauts who died on previous
missions when Apollo 11 Departed the
moon Buzz Aldrin and Neil Armstrong had
to leave over 100 items behind this was
to lighten the load so they could return
to Earth some of those items included
cameras space gear and of course the U.S
flag but one of the more interesting
items was a small silicone disc it was
engraved with almost 100 messages from
NASA employees as well as from U.S and
world leaders these are all pretty weird
but you know what's weirder some of the
lies you've been told about space Did
you know that the sun isn't yellow but
an entirely different color
what is it well that's a story for
another what if
foreign